winning an Oscar ages you hello there
thank you for having me back it's such a
pleasure to be here last year was the
best night of my husband's life
he actually says that and I've given
birth three times
so I I hope you're all having as good a
time as he did and decided um I don't
want to keep you from the bar much
longer I know I'm supposed to talk about
acting and find some clever thread
connecting these performances but their
beauty and brilliance surely lies in the
fact that there isn't one and I'm sorry
that all these men can't win here are
the nominees for performance by an actor
in a leading role
Antonio Banderas Payne and Hillary
[Applause]
Leonardo DiCaprio once upon a time in
Hollywood
Adam driver marriage story
[Applause]
Joaquin Phoenix Joker
jonathan pryce the two popes
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Joaquin Phoenix
toca this is the first Oscar and fourth
nomination for Joaquin Phoenix
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta move so much data too right now
uh and I do not feel elevated above any
my fellow nominees or anyone in this
room because we share the same love that
the love of film and this form of
expression has given me the most
extraordinary life I don't know what I'd
be without it but I think the greatest
gift that it's given me and many of us
in this room is the opportunity to use
our voice for the voiceless I've been
thinking a lot about some of the
distressing issues that we are facing
collectively and I think at times we
feel or were made to feel that we
champion different causes but for me I
see commonality I think whether we're
talking about gender inequality or
racism or queer rights or indigenous
rights or animal rights we're talking
about the fight against injustice we're
talking about the fight against the
belief that one nation one people one
race one gender or one species has the
right to dominate control and use and
exploit another with impunity I think
that we've become very disconnected from
the natural world and many of us what
were guilty of is an egocentric
worldview the belief that were the
center of the universe we go into the
natural world and we plunder it for its
resources we feel entitled to
artificially inseminate a cow and when
she gives birth we steal her baby even
though her cries of anguish are
unmistakable and then we take her milk
that's intended for a calf and we put it
in our coffee and our cereal
and I think we fear the idea of personal
change because we think that we have to
sacrifice something to give something up
but human beings that our best are so
inventive and creative and ingenious and
I think that when we use love and
compassion as our dieting principles we
can create develop and implement systems
of change that are beneficial to all
sentient beings and to the environment
now I've been I've been a scoundrel in
my life I've been selfish I've been
cruel at times hard to work with and
ungrateful but so many of you in this
room have given me a second chance and I
think that's when we're at our best when
when we support each other not when we
cancel each other out for past mistakes
but when we help each other to grow when
we educate each other when we guide each
other towards redemption that is the
best of humanity
I just um
when you when he was up when he was when
he was 17 my brother wrote over this
lyric he said run to the rescue with
love and peace will follow thank you
[Applause]